hey everybody it's Mike Frieda here with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control m a DOT
l2-3.7.5 require multi-factor
authentication to establish non-local
maintenance sessions via external
network connections and terminate such
connections when non-local maintenance
is complete wow
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so uh this control has a few
interesting parts and I'm going to
quickly break them down first is the
requirement for MFA on non-local
maintenance sessions so even if the
non-local maintenance person isn't
touching cui but they're able to do
maintenance on a network that contains
cui MFA is still required generally
speaking you can assume that any
external access to an enclave or network
contains cui probably requires
multi-factor authentication let's just
change that one to definitely period end
of story now the second part is to make
sure the connection terminates when
maintenance is complete so why so that
you know so the answer so the question
is why and that's so that we don't
accidentally leave the window open at
night for our teenage daughter's
boyfriend sneak the window at night
because you know how that goes so yes
many attacks actually occur due to I.T
administrators and other maintenance
Personnel leaving the door wide open and
walking away here's an example I.T
Personnel are doing maintenance on the
network from home they never do that
right of course not of course they would
uh they get up and leave the house to go
get some pizza
super stereotypical why has got to be
Pizza I love pizza as it turns out their
local home PC is compromised and the
evil hackers are just waiting for the
alarm that the system has been idle for
exactly 14 minutes which is usually one
minute right before the screensaver
kicks on locks them out they jump in and
if that main session doesn't have an
automated lockout mechanism guess what
the evil hackers just got access to your
entire network through somebody's home
computer so again there's a lot of
really great reasons to have this
control in place it's very logical and
uh you know ultimately this is one of
the most common kinds of attack
okay we're an out-of-band computer is
compromised and gets access to the
secured Network so we become much safer
when that maintenance session terminates
automatically upon completion of the
work or a very short idle time
thereafter and it needs to be automatic
okay time to see what the assessors want
on this one so two things you're looking
for one determine if multi-factor
authentication is used to establish
non-local maintenance sessions via
external network connections uh again
how do we answer that one well we could
say it's implemented non-local access is
not possible without MFA why because we
probably have MFA on our VPN or uh you
know whatever connection we're using to
get in second one is determine if
non-local maintenance sessions establish
via external network connections are
terminated when non-local minutes is
complete this one's a little bit more
challenging but again per the it
operations policy non-local Mania
sessions should be terminated upon
completion of the maintenance session a
Fail-Safe is in place to automatically
terminate the session after 15 minutes
as a Fail-Safe so again great way to
kind of solve all that in two different
ways but there's definitely a concrete
fail safe there now if you're a defense
contractor and I know you are because
you wouldn't be watching this video
unless you are or maybe you're not a
defense contractor and you wish you were
well here's the good news right because
uh at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like a seal on a sunny day can we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you haven't put on your
cape lately you know what it's looking
over the corner and you're like man my
Cape is like a little bit Rusty it's
okay man you can put it back on and you
know what we'll even help you button up
so you can go fly be a superhero for
your company
shh hey if you're looking for more get
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you to feed Superman really awesome
jokes visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerves
roll it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below I love your
comments they make us laugh they make us
cry sometimes they make us want to like
go have a beer but I love them all and
you should know that and if you're
watching this video and you're still
watching this video I would love to hear
your comments because we care
I lost my line that's what happened
there that awkward pause wasn't really
because I care that much there's like a
certain amount of awkward pause that you
can allow for sincerity I blew it that
was really really long I do care that
much but I don't want to show you that I
care that much it's like you know it is
like a first date kind of thing this
might be your 70th video but this is
like our first date anyway here's the
bottom line I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]